hey what's up welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artist react
Peter Peter is here I don't know how
this has never happened before now but
Peter has finally joined us on the couch
here I'm glad you guys have finally
stooped to this level it's it's nice to
uh have have me met at the bottom yeah
trust me we had no
[Music]
choice neither did
I we're going to be looking at some
Godzilla effects from all these
different movies back in the day oh
pretty also we had a really cool
opportunity to interview the director of
the newest Godzilla movie Godzilla minus
one but did you bring some clips for us
today I did bring some clips you know
Godzilla has quite a variety of quality
I got some great Godzilla clips to show
you guys and I got some silly bad ones
to show you guys I'm very excited ooh
some silly Clips huh silly Clips dog
silly Godzilla
[Music]
clippies so guys I think we should start
off strong with maybe the best Godzilla
effects I've ever seen you guys are
going to love
this is that what's going on here wait
hold up hold up is that versus giant
Cricket pretty much oh my gosh oh my
gosh
W he's so goofy and friendly looking I
love the way he moves he's like a baby
Godzilla he's got so much personality in
his eyes also Ultram man and the bug are
getting back up for round two I guess
yeah and the bug is just like cool with
it
now I love the velocity at which he's
tra he's like up and
then just tail sliding so um as VFX
artist how how do you guys think they
did obviously it's like dudes in suits
but it's kind of well done I mean I I
don't see any wires I don't see any
wires like the background looks like
it's a proper scale like those are trees
we're seeing even though they're
miniature this is pretty great I like it
the visual effects I gave a A+ where
where is this energy today CGI
[Music]
boring so for the 1984 Godzilla movie
and they were like okay we're building a
16t tall Godzilla robot and it was
really cool it mostly worked but what's
tragic is I guess it didn't look very
good because they removed almost all of
the shots with this from the American
release oh no and there are only a
couple shots because the eyes
malfunctioned and they would kind of
look in different direction oh no so it
just looked really
[Music]
silly and there it
is wait let me see it again come
on Prett yeah so they're like we can't
put this in the I'm
God I love the Practical explosives on
this kind of stuff just slow motion like
the smoke curling around the costumes I
guess one of the benefits of building a
giant animatronic is that your like
smoke and fire scales better yeah
totally wa and then this is probably the
rubber suit I think that's what they
used for the majority of this movie
still I think my problem with this that
we're seeing right now is that it looks
like a miniature set you know like the
little spaceship thing definitely looks
like it's about this big yeah although
here they did a good job combining the
miniature plate with all of the crowd
there in 1984 that's a full-on comp shot
that they were having to do yeah they
did a good job matching the colors and
like the feel of the lighting and all
yeah it actually looks pretty good yeah
so there's a new Godzilla coming
out Peter have you seen the trailer for
the new movie yet yes I have I watched
it yesterday it looks great it looks
really exciting I wish I hadn't but uh
I'll react as if I can lie here ask me
ask me again Peter have you seen the
trailer for the new Godzilla yet I no I
[Music]
haven't
this looks very good that looks like
real like footage of an aircraft flying
over this Battleship and then of course
you got Godzilla underneath the water
but you can get away with like you know
doing some like transparency things and
making it look like it's under the water
at the end of the day it's like this is
probably just a full CG shot I bet it's
full CG the challenge with doing full CG
shots like this is that you have all the
interaction around the boat and the
ocean surface often times you just get
away with that being footage of the
ocean or a separate thing but trying to
get them to react like you see on the
edges of the wake you have now the
ripples going into the ocean kind of
makes you have to do the whole thing now
as like one big Sim and then it just
gets really heavy so we just looked at
Space Battleship Yamato dude that's the
freaking space
Titanic you captain and coincidentally
the same director is a director of
Godzilla minus one and they reached out
to us after having seen our Shin
Godzilla clip to ask if we'd like to
talk to him about the movie is he get
that
yeah so the biggest challenge was
tackling know those massive bodies of
water just the water on its own was 500
terabytes we're trying to set up all the
the computing power that's possible but
we're running them down so we actually
had to just it was this cat and mouse
Chase of you know locking down VFX but
we needed more more machines more power
more
everything I do really like the design
of this Godzilla we've seen so many
different permutations you know back in
the day he was kind of just like a tall
lizard even like the more modern
interpretations of Godzilla he's still
kind of lizard-like whereas this guy
looks like a monster even Shin Godzilla
which we looked at recently was kind of
like that towering just I'm a walking
statue but I'm very sharp and prickly
whereas this guy has that same prickly
nature while still feeling like Oh I'm a
monster that can move I feel like the
best way to describe it would be to say
cragly cragly what was your biggest
inspiration for the design of the new
Godzilla
so my intention with my Godzilla was for
it to be scary and cool you know I was
able to just really delve into the
character design using zbrush and of
course you know and then it goes to the
downstream process and someone much
better than me finishes it but at least
I'm able to send off exactly the kind of
Godzilla I was looking for point out I
was director and the screenwriter and
the V effect supervisor so it was really
great to just go from script all the way
to post produ the entire process because
when I'm writing the script I could also
keep in mind how much time something
would take how many crew we would need
so I can keep that in mind as I'm
writing it once we got into the VFX
portion of post then I'm actually
reviewing all the VFX as are coming out
so I think compared to a different
production all those VFX checks were
able to happen more much much more
frequently I do feel it's a way you need
to do it for a movie like this like to
have your director be the visual effect
supervisor on a Godzilla movie is
important cuz like the whole thing is
effects not to pick on Marvel
necessarily there's obviously some great
Marvel stuff but there's also a lot of
Marvel stuff where it's like an actor's
director and then the fight scene
happens and it's like that was made by a
different team
yeah yeah so for example you know
obviously you know I have my Crews you
know we divy up the different scenes but
then over time you know deadlines start
getting missed and things like that and
we fall behind so end up buy my own
computer and doing it myself spoken like
a true VFX
artist so big Shout to Godzilla minus
one and the team for sponsoring this
video letting us talk to the director
it's out in theaters now there's a link
in the description below if you want to
go check it out find a theater near you
that's playing it and we even have a
little exclusive clip only for this
channel here it
is
foree
[Music]
[Applause]
fore
[Music]
what
allit this is 7
November so I didn't particularly grow
up with the Japanese Godzilla movies
even though they're very inherently
Japanese but I did see the Godzilla that
came out in 1998 when I was a kid and I
loved this movie and looking back on it
so many years later I'm really impressed
by the decision making behind the visual
effects the visual effects in this movie
are
insane how do you think they did that
with the water going up like that that
looks practical I can tell you so for
this sequence they literally just had a
smaller version of the pier that they
put in the water and had a scale
Godzilla model they just shot through it
really fast and so that's all miniature
right there and the guy is comped in WoW
ah okay sure
wow God this so well done that is a
Flawless shot like you watch that it's
like it doesn't look like V effect it
just look like a real shot of this
happening yeah not at all like the
reflection of him and the you know the
wetness of the yeah also notice how they
have the chain leak fence in front of
all of it to really make it look like
it's all combined there that's really
clever
yeah now this is the shot that I
remember most from the movie it's such a
big moment between the joking of like
trying to get the cassette tape in it
and be
[Music]
like and then almost getting squished by
a footstep this is like an every trailer
shot I really missed the vibe of early
2000s movies where CG was good enough
where they could mix it with super
expensive practical effects what's
really interesting about this is that if
you look at just Godzilla and the
rendering and shading on it it looks
dated and yet the implementation of it
with all of the footage holds up having
the all the cars actually move having
the camera Shake just right having the
actual footprint of Godzilla like Left
Behind as it moves away it makes for an
iconic moment even all the water around
his feet that Splash up at the crater
the thing that makes a CGI look dated to
me you don't have fine intricate ambient
occlusion you only have like generalized
Shadows so even though Godzilla has this
bumpy crazy texture on its skin you
don't have the detail to be able to go
in with the lighting and render the
Shadows that should be in those wrinkles
and crevices and all that kind of stuff
which it looks like there's maybe some
of that going on with the painted
texture you know they put some ambient
occlusion like baked into the texture
but it's funny how a lot of modern CGI
that technically looks really good we
say looks bad and something like this
where the CGI itself isn't rendered
using modern techniques so it looks a
little dated but it's still it has so
much attention to detail that we like
it I think they also went to the
Jurassic Park School of lighting here
yeah and it's raining just like in
Jurassic Park how much you want to bet
they literally like tried to take every
lesson from Jurassic Park and was like
all right we're going to take all that
and apply it here yep probably 100% that
looks pretty d good that does not look
as dated as those first few shots did I
could be wrong but I also wouldn't be
surprised if they actually made a
physical mikette and like use pictures
and stuff like that for textures and you
know basing a lot this on physical
[Music]
modeling this is insane that's the
compositing here is like we're talking
about CGI but like from a compositing
point of view this is insane compositing
even now this is insane compositing to
have a shot that looks like this with
this kind of compositing like this
window shot matching all of the lighting
like they got the glow from that you
know sign behind it casting onto the
back edge of Godzilla all the street
lights and everything W like that one
shot there I think is probably the best
looking shot in the whole movie like
this holds up so dang
[Music]
well
Godzilla Godzilla 2000 Godzilla 2000
super cool it came out right after the
American Godzilla that came out but it's
a classic japanese Godzilla model work
suits this is like the last of its kind
this is the Pinnacle this is the end of
the classic Godzilla techniques here and
it's pretty
crazy dang that looks good so for this
shot do you think that's Force
perspective or do you think that's a
comp oh it's definitely it's definitely
a comp yeah it's a dude in a water tank
and they're just masking it out looks
perfect yeah yeah no that is that is
pretty good but you can see the scale of
the water ripples there yeah and they
but they did a really good job
Feathering that out to match it into the
ocean they got the color of the water
right too mhm yes wait whoa wait wait
whoa is that a motion control shot wait
yeah or just no that's comped it's
comped it's definitely comped somehow
and the camera is moving you know what I
think it might be Godzilla on a
treadmill walking towards camera and
they just scaled him down yeah you can
see they're doing their dangest to keep
those feet on the ground and it's hand
Tred for sure there was no 3D tracking
when they made
this love the explosives of the costume
look so good wow that costume is on fire
yeah God the water stuff looks pretty
dang good like this shot looks great
whoa FL your arms and scream if you're
okay I'm on fire I'm
drowning I'm on fire and I'm in 3T of
water water in a rubber suit and I can't
move help
[Music]
me oh yeah wow love it w this stuff's
really cool I like watching Miniatures
like this get blown up filmers don't
need to hide that it's a miniature like
I like that it's a miniature like that's
why I'm here it's like making a Toy
Story movie and being like I hope nobody
notices it's CGI it's like no it's okay
I like watching Miniatures blow
up I also still have no idea what the
ropes are oh my God this is
brutal
whoa It's also interesting to note how
model buildings fall over completely
differently when people aren't doing it
in CGI like when you can't direct it to
fracture and all these little pieces and
it has to like fall over in chunks oh my
goodness
oh that building had a nuclear bomb in
it these comp shots are really well done
it's like it just shows how far you can
go go with like basic CGI as long as you
film all your stuff and put together
like real plates all right well we
looked at a ton of Godzilla clips if
there are any other themes you have
ideas for that we should take a look at
leave them in the comment section below
let us know maybe we'll take a look
Peter what do you think you know what
it's an honor to be on this couch I feel
like I'm fulfilling some sort of Destiny
here and uh glad it's with you too and
uh this was a lot of fun thanks for
having me yeah I mean I'd love to have
you on the couch again okay next week
all right I'll be here next week I mean
I will be here next week I already got
it scheduled so see you then for next on
animators react with Aaron Blaze stay
tuned subscribe for that wow you must
have done this before yeah